MARKUS KLUTE:
Welcome back to 8.20.
In the previous section, we have
seen the relativistic Doppler
effect, and now we want
to study how light--
in this case, a
monochromatic plane wave--
transforms in the
Lorentz transformation.
In other words, we have,
for example, a distant star
emitting light at a
specific frequency.
The question now is, how
do we observe this light
when the star is traveling
away from us or towards us?
So here you see our
monochromatic plane wave.
We have an amplitude A and
then just a simple cosine,
which is a function
of x, y, and t, time.
This is the solution
of the wave equation,
and we have already seen
this as part of the p
sets, but also
discussed in class.
So the wave is characterized
by so-called wave numbers
in x direction and y direction.
The squared sum-- the square
root of the squared sum
is the so-called wave number.
The frequency omega
is equal to 2 pi f,
where f is the frequency and
omega is the angular frequency.
And if you divide the angular
frequency by the wave number,
you get the speed of light.
Similarly, you can multiply the
frequency and the wavelength.
OK, so as a first
activity, I will
ask you to see that how
does this solution, how
does this specific wave,
transform on the Lorentz
transformation?
As a reminder, we have seen
that the equation which
governs how this
light propagates
is [INAUDIBLE] the
Lorentz transformation.
But now we want to
investigate what
happens to the wave itself.
OK?
So we have to investigate this
specific solution and Lorentz
transform x and t.
And I just do this
here in this equation.
So you see that now we
have, as part of the cosine,
Kx gamma x prime plus beta
ct prime plus no change in y
direction as we look at
the Lorentz transformation
in x direction, and then we have
the transformation of the time
axis.
OK?
So now this looks very
cumbersome or complicated,
but we can try to refind the
very same characterization
of the wave as we had before.
How does now the transformed
wave number look like or does
the frequency look like
after Lorentz transformation?
And so we want to identify
the individual terms Kx prime,
where we label Kx
prime as the parameter
you find here in the solution,
in this Lorentz transform
solution, and we do the
same for omega prime,
and you find a solution here.
So now there's
this angle cosine I
defined as the angle with
respect to the line of motion.
Omega prime is now the baseline
frequency and omega the one
which is detected.
That's just a matter of
changing the direction of beta
with the plus and minus sign.
But if we use that definition,
we can now discuss the result.
So as part of the discussion,
we can look at the specific case
where the wave is
moving towards us.
OK?
So zeta is equal to 0
and beta is positive.
In this case, omega is
larger than omega prime.
And so the frequency
is going to be higher.
So the detected frequency is
going to be higher blueshifted.
So if you have a situation that
a star is moving up towards us
and emitting light, the light
is detected by us, maybe
by our eyes or by a
telescope, that light
is going to be blueshifted.
It's going to go to
higher frequencies.
The opposite scenario is where
zeta is equal to 180 degrees
and beta equal to--
greater than 0, or
the other way around.
We could have defined
this also as zeta
equals 0 and beta negative.
In this case, omega is
smaller than omega prime.
So the frequency
is lower, meaning
that the light we
observe is redshifted.
And therefore,
this term redshift
is a measure of whether
or not the source of light
is moving towards
us or away from us.
And the larger the redshift,
the higher the velocity
is of this object
moving away from us.
So we can define this redshift
as the relative change
in frequency omega prime
minus omega over omega,
or we can define 1 plus
Z, 1 plus the redshift
is omega prime over omega,
which is square root of 1
plus beta over 1 minus beta.
All right?
So if you now observe
the stars in our galaxy,
and you can do
this, for example,
by its specific spectral form.
There are the specific
spectral lines,
lines of specific
frequency, which
we can observe
from stars as they
are in certain distance
from our solar system.
And if we do this, we basically
see all stars being redshifted,
meaning all stars are actually
moving away from us, which
is a measure of the fact that
the universe is expanding.